[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
so you ran into chris at the after party
yeah bro so it was pretty wild so spade
took me over to the um
who actually is from arizona shout out i
think he's from scottsdale hey uh so
spade invited me to be his his uh guest
or whatever we went to the um
vanity fair party
and then we went to some other dude a
rich guy's house this dude was really
really rich like they had a machine in
the front you could just get money out
of it it was just like it was a hp okay
but you could guess any number and it
gave you it was like this dude was real
real rich like yeah they had even his
dog had like a little wallet on the side
dude
yeah so this dude was really really rich
and we went in and like
jennifer lawrence is sitting in the back
just hanging out outside like just in
her pajamas she like lived next door i
guess and so she came over because she
heard some commotion or whatever so
she's out back just hanging out like
there's like pelling out the
pellanepi cruise
um fancy people i mean it's like fancy
people you see on the magazine and
they're just sitting there you know
eating you know they had some raviolis
um what else did they have they had a
salad that looked
it was a little wet i thought a little
bit of wilted but people were eating it
rich people will eat
they'll eat kind of more with they'll
say it's like uh more artistic kind of
but anyway so
we get to finally see chris rock right
and so and i'm with david spade so spade
knows him so
they're just kind of talking and he was
just shocked he was like what the [ __ ]
happened he's almost it reminded me of
you ever been at a party and somebody
gets hit by somebody and then the person
that hit him leaves
and there was never really like a big
fight or maybe there even was a fight
but the one dude never had any idea
there was any beef or anything going on
and then you start talking to that guy
and he's like bro what the [ __ ] happened
like what what do you think you know
that's kind of what it was he was just
like what the [ __ ] so did he not know
that she had alopecia or whatever
disease that's why she was bald did he
not know that i think he had no clue i
think he had no clue
and who don't have alopecia everybody's
going bald you want to hear something
funny i i saw a tweet that said it
wasn't even rock's joke it was one of
the writers that's so good what do you
think he's doing backstage but after the
writer just like
here's the thing yeah the writer
probably thought of way worse jokes
about infidelity and was like let's go
with something mild dude she's wearing a
green like a military green outfit yeah
and is she gonna be in gij
no no you're not making another gi jane
no no she's not doing this for a role
what
what do you mean
what do you mean no no she's doing it
because she has alopecia she's losing
her hair yeah which is apparently a huge
deal i had no idea
every person at the oscars has fake hair
every person in this room is losing
their hair yeah yeah
but no for real like if there's one
place where you can wear like wigs and
fake hair and all that kind of stuff
it's the uh like every girl there
probably has extensions yeah but you
want to be proud she wanted to come out
and say yo this is my hair well they
keep it a buck be proud
you don't go and sit in the front row
you're a star at the oscars there's a
professional comedian whose job is to
roast people
that's what he's doing and what he did
was not even insulting it's not it was a
mild joke that was not an insult it was
the most mild joke about her hairstyle i
fully get into a movie where he shaved
her head i fully get it simply any
justification whatsoever of him getting
up there and smacking him in the face
but fancy's not losing his hair the way
that carlos says he's like the mexican
larry david he's like luis dabid
he is
and carlos is uh
what are you doing
keep carlos's name out of your [ __ ]
mouth
dude it was like a mexican larry david
joke i was keep carlos's name out of
your [ __ ] mouth
okay dude when i first saw it i was like
yeah
because he bought me twice no chris rock
rock friday and saturday i wasn't able
to go up
no he no he's a nice guy i'm just saying
there was a little problem was like dad
you know don't bump
you know i mean and then eric made a
little meme
of the celebrities that don't be bumping
people into or i mean so um
which is funny but when you really think
about it because it was a moment
um
after
will said don't ever [ __ ] talk about
my couple times he said that
um
where chris
i know that love because i've been there
it's a moment of shock
and trauma
it was traumatic
um he was assaulted
um in front of millions and trillions of
people i mean
not millions of people
watch the but
virally i mean you're talking about the
world saw it the whole world russians
putin saw it
i bet you martin putin's on it what do
you think weighs more no chris rock or
the hair in the shower
[Laughter]
he was doing some weird movie thing it
was like he was getting away with it as
if he was living in a fictional movie
like the idea that you think it's smart
while wearing a tuxedo to walk onto a
stage in front of the world like
literally the world one of the biggest
award shows on earth if not the biggest
and smack a comedian for the most mild
joke and then sit there quivering saying
keep my wife's name out of your [ __ ]
mouth and everybody's just going to sit
there in the [ __ ] that you just took on
the table you just pulled your pants
down and took a [ __ ] on the dinner table
and they all have just sit there and
look at that that's what it's like
full of peanuts and corn and everything
it stinks it's just the whole idea
behind it is completely irrational but
what i'm saying is like these people
live in this
fake world of you know
you're you're protected by guards you're
driven by limos you're on the red carpet
you know like all of it is crazy life
and he's so goddamn famous and so
so removed from regular discourse and
interaction with regular people that he
for whatever reason in his head acted
like he's a character in a movie yeah
yeah there was a guy there was a guy uh
a writer there and i remember him saying
i don't think that it was real
and i'm like i don't think the acting
could be that great that way bro um
and so yeah then we ended up at the
party and then rock was there which i
thought was the cool movies at the party
he's not like ducking anything you know
i think he thought it was really weird
he didn't look like affected he didn't
have like a little cast on his jaw or
nothing imagine me and collider in the
audience we'll never go there but we'll
never yeah
and chriska look at collider with her
heart defect or something right yeah
and people are laughing right there's
something worse about my um my um the
way i look not so much stanley bobby lee
is dating stanley tucci
stanley tucci is here right right
and i kind of laugh
right and i look over and you're upset
right
i would look what if you said this even
worse okay go ahead
i'm in the audience yeah
looks so much like stanley tucci he
hasn't [ __ ] her in two years
no you have to look upset
then i look back up here
and i look at you and i go
[Laughter]
we're on tv smile [ __ ]
we're on tv [ __ ]
there's billions of people [ __ ] we're
millionaires [ __ ]
you mean you can take that that's true
now question guys jada pinkett smith's
hair condition you think that's actually
alopecia or it's all like the r b
singers just rubbing her head oh my gosh
they said that her head is like the new
log from the apollo rose
well you thought i was gonna give all
the rose jokes in the intro
come on so we gotta have a couple
leftovers for the conversation
you wrote that you could have a career
oh my god
here's what happened right afterwards he
won the academy award then goes up and
does a speech the whole thing was so
bizarre and it made me think like how
many other human beings could be in a
similar situation and pull that off
plenty like if a man walked on stage and
smacked a woman no that would not fly
would not fly
if a woman walked on stage and smacked
another woman i don't even think it
would fly i would love to see if the
rock said something instead of chris
rock then is it keep my wife's name out
i'm gonna give you one what if it was
what if it was jimmy kimmel well if it
was a white dude well if it was ricky
uh will smith ain't hitting him yeah
yeah that's probably right what do you
think al i don't think he's hitting him
i don't know i think will was fed up i
think that
this is the thing i think it could have
been anybody i think will was fed up and
then he took it out on somebody he knew
he could get away with taking it out
yeah which is why he's so [ __ ] he's
known him for like 25 years but he's
also amazing
i want to make a point about that he did
make jokes and pass i want to make
another point nobody in that room is
rooting for chris rock
what do you mean keep this in mind all
the people in that crowd
have been made fun of by chris rock for
the last decade these are people who
live in their own little hollywood
bubbles nobody ever gives a pushback
nobody ever teases them nobody ever says
nothing to these people they don't have
a sense of humor you go see these shows
and they're like groaning about all
these jokes and then applauding when the
joke is virtuous right yeah they see
every they have to go to these events
because they want the public uh applause
yeah they want the public validation but
they know that they're gonna get caught
in the crosshairs from a chris rock joke
and it drives them crazy and they were
happy did you see the way samuel jackson
dapped up
will smith
did you see the way that denzel and
bradley cooper watch it watch out yeah
denzel a loser
i gotta give credit come over there
smack you right now
i will
at a certain point it looks like he
thinks that it's gonna be he's joking
yeah
and then i'm sure at a certain point i
bet it was very close quarters when the
energy probably changed in his mind he's
like oh this is not a joke what do i do
do you think rock did the best thing
that he could have done yes he literally
his new toy is called ego death antonio
brown
getting slapped at the oscars and not
doing nothing you can't have an ego
about that bro
and he can't even come back and make
jokes about will yes he can yes he can
there's two types of black people
every time black people want to have a
good time will smith come and [ __ ] it up
that's good
it's good
yo smith always wants some credit for
some [ __ ] you're supposed to do
i protect my family you supposed to you
dumb [ __ ]
beat my full fit my i hate will smith
the media you think when i'm at the
oscars i'm looking in the audience for
the media no i'm looking for will smith
it was a rare instance where someone is
so enormously famous and successful like
will smith that they literally still
allowed him to not just win the academy
award but also go up and accept it and
give a speech after he assaulted a small
comedian yeah they should have rejected
him they should have ejected him from
the 100
100
i agree with that you don't just you
can't just go smack a man in the face in
front of the world and then go about
business as usual first of all it sets a
terrible precedent yes
in in so many different ways it's a
terrible precedent for comedy clubs yes
like are people going to decide that
they're going to go on stage and smack
the comedian i hope they try to smack
brendan or you
just want to see one joe rogan turning
sidekick yeah
chuggy i i don't i don't necessarily
think people are going to change their
behavior but dumb people might but also
it's like what are we saying as a
society when the the people that we look
up to for whatever reason for good or
for bad we look up to actors yes and and
the academy awards is supposed to be
them in their most regal
their most regal outfits their best
behavior yeah and to
drop down to violence for something so
innocuous as a gi jane joke what rematch
would you rather see
mosby doll
verse colby or rock versus smith
rockford smith probably just because i
don't know how that plays out but colby
vs jorge
i think i mean
i think that plays out pretty similar to
how it played out the first time yeah i
agree well how much bigger is will than
chris
i think at least 50 pounds i know that
how tall is chris you mind checking that
out
how tall is chris rock
10.
wow i wonder if either can scrap will
smith is six one and a half
did you measure about the oscars uh he
looked it up oh oh he did and then i got
border looking it up because i was
trying to figure out the weights or
whatever and i just went to sleep and
here's what comedians had to say on
twitter tim dillon said okay but also
this must be said that was all great
television from the slap to the speech
before that the oscars was incredibly
boring and tame we found the formula a
rocky marriage a violent attack a
redemption arc what a show
andrew santino said it's a comedian's
responsibility to always know their
audience and that includes everyone's
medical history likes and dislikes mark
norman tweeted about 600 times since
this happened but two of my favorites
were thank god chris rock didn't take a
shot at alec baldwin and also i bet
chris rock is having a real jerk store
moment right now the ocean call they're
running out of shrimp yeah yeah yeah but
then i said to him oh yeah well the jerk
store called and they're running out of
you
really that's great you said that to him
well actually i thought it up on the way
over here
oh that's not quite the same no
that's not
you don't know this guy it would have
been so sweet tom segura i thought was a
little soft on will smith all he had to
say was [ __ ] will smith's candy ass
smacking a dude four inches shorter and
50 pounds lighter he's just in his
feelings because his bald headed [ __ ]
been [ __ ] around on him for years and
he takes it we all know who he wishes he
could have slacked
slapped hashtag cuck will he also
tweeted these four pictures of her bald
ass head and said this [ __ ] bin bald
jokes about it or her are fine it was
tam af you were super sensitive about it
buy a [ __ ] wig and finally samurail
said will smith just won an award for
being the best actor but he couldn't act
like a human being during a joke and he
also said this was the biggest hit will
smith has been involved in since the 90s
so
all around um crazy thing that happened
here's every comedian's take on it i'm
sure no one will care about this in a
few weeks but it was fun while it lasted
make sure you subscribe to joke world
follow us on instagram thanks for
watching and more videos coming soon
[Music]
you